à chaque jour sa nouvelle candidature
aux etats-unis le célèbre milliardaire
donald trump 69 ans annonce qu'il va
concourir pour la présidentielle côté
républicain juin 2015
derrière ce petit sourire un brin
moqueur david pujadas dresse le portrait
du nouveau candidat à la maison blanche
donald trump le ton du sujet se veut pas
d'un kart personne à l'époque n'imaginez
cet homme à la tête des états unis pas
même les autres candidats républicains
si on adopte son langage de division et
de haine on ne va jamais gagné les mois
passent les polémiques et xénophobes et
les provocations s'enchaînent et ce
candidat fait toujours figure de blagues
de notre at-il une réelle chance
d'emporter l'investiture républicaine
la plupart des observateurs politiques
ici estime que donald trump n'est qu'une
bulle un phénomène éphémère qui va faire
pschitt
même les instituts de sondage n'imagine
pas donald trump président à 6 mois de
l'investiture républicaine ses
concurrents ne mâchaient pas leurs mots
cette couse son principal rival condamne
je bouge et le plus radical
trump est un déséquilibré ditty
conclusion du journaliste à l'époque
personne ne peut sérieusement imaginer
un pareil personnage à la maison blanche
pourtant on
juillet 2016 aux etats unis toujours ces
faits donald trump sera bien le candidat
républicain dans la course à la maison
blanche il a officiellement été désigné
la nuit dernière par les délégués du
parti juillet 2016
on connaît les deux principaux
finalistes qui s'affronteront en
novembre hillary clinton pour les
démocrates et donald trump pour les
républicains
certains républicains se désolidarise et
jettent leur accréditation
pire ils remettent en cause l'aptitude
du candidat plus de 50 république un
spécialiste de la sécurité nationale
avait attaqué donald trump dans une
lettre ouverte
s'il est élu distille il sera le
président le plus dangereux de toute
l'histoire des états unis
mais le 8 novembre 2016 alors que toute
la presse imaginer hillary clinton à la
maison blanche la surprise la
stupéfaction personne ne l'excluaient
mais personne ne s'y attendait vraiment
il ya encore ici ce soir comme un
sentiment d'irréalité à donald trump l'a
donc emporté contre toutes les
prévisions
le président sortant se représente pour
un deuxième mandat
persuadé de l'emporter cette fois ci
journalistes et instituts de sondages
seront sûrement plus modérés dans leurs
pronostics
[Musique]